these Malian recruits are preparing for
a military exercise about a thousand
soldiers are being trained as part of a
mission to make the Malian army more
professional some 20 countries are part
of the European Union training mission
in Mali France has the largest
contingent in this exercise British
French and German trainers have created
a scenario that is as realistic as
possible
see the hospital assist us the point of
this session is to tackle a camp of
jihadis who are planning an attack on
Coleco the Malian army is still short of
almost everything logistics
transmissions and even officers Mali was
long considered to be a model of
democracy in Africa but a coup d'etat
almost two years ago plunged the country
into turmoil
the UN's minusma mission was established
last year to carry out a series of
security related stabilisation tasks
although UN resolutions provide for
around 12,000 soldiers the force
currently has only half of that the head
of the mission has called for help we
need support for the jinnee for the
engineering we need to support in terms
of the so called enablers medical
support for our troops and that remains
important so I think I would call on all
Member States to continue to support us
in this
Germany's role is largely logistical
Bundeswehr transyl's have been deployed
to transport soldiers and equipment in
Mali the transport often happens under
extreme conditions the high temperatures
are also a factor with regard to the
aircraft's performance precise
calculations have to be made about what
loads can be transported for what
distance at what temperature some
flights can only take place in the
morning when it's still relatively cool
the planes can carry 80 people or 10
tons of material the pilots are
particularly well trained as they have
to be able to land almost anywhere the
challenges in terms of flying are most
definitely landing on dirt runways that
come as well as the challenges with the
environment and the temperatures if in
northern Mali we fly on two gravel
runways and you need to use a particular
maneuver to land the first November
round of parliamentary elections took
place largely peacefully a second round
is scheduled for mid December the German
ambassador is aware of the importance of
stability especially as many Malian
refugees have sought asylum in Germany
instead of us we have to be aware of the
fact that Africans are our neighbors our
neighbors in Europe that's also true of
Mali security and development in Mali
directly affect our interests we open
once the ones were interested in on
metal bar buyers
it's unclear how long German troops will
remain in Mali and how long the
international mission will be in place
the aim is to hand over responsibility
to the Malian army as soon as possible
we're going to gradually train Malian
trainers who will come to us to form
battalions both in Kuniko during the
centralised phase as well as in the
Garrison's during the decentralized face
they will progressively take on the role
of the European contingent which will
contribute to the exit strategy but
until then intensive training will
continue troops still have to learn the
basics such as how to evaluate a
situation secure a bridge or search for
explosives from the Germans as you can
see today the exercise we were told that
70 meters of the bridge are mined so son
Dmitri symmetric my men are checking to
see if there are any cables or
explosives on the road apart from the
necessary training what's also missing
in the Malian army is equipment
and the communication structures are not
up to scratch either communication in
the sense of superiors giving
information to the soldiers and troops
reporting back so superiors know what's
going on and they can make the right
decisions it's generally accepted that
the Malian army is currently not in a
position to deal with armed rebels but
the EU trainers are optimistic about the
future two battle groups are currently
through with their training two more
will follow I have to say that after
their basic training we've managed to
create a group of people who believe in
themselves who will hopefully carry out
their mission in the north all plugger
for food they will soon be put to the
test Tuareg rebels in the north have
just announced their intentions to go
back to war with the Malian army just
six months after signing a ceasefire